this video was made possible by class
central you can sit in on thousands of
college courses taught by world-class
professors at the greatest universities
in the world right now by visiting the
link in the description class -
central.com slash Pakman let's talk
about astrology in the simplest sense
astrology means the search for human
meaning in the sky astrology is a belief
system and practice which claims that
the movement and positions of celestial
bodies like stars and planets and the
moon can give us answers about what's
happening on earth and can make
predictions about what will happen on
earth and in human lives astrologers
believe that the movement and
positioning of celestial bodies even
have an effect on human personalities
and behavior so an astrologer might
assert that it wasn't a coincidence that
someone died during a full moon or that
a person is likely to make good
decisions in their love life this week
because they were born on a certain day
in March fifty years ago the problem
with astrology is common to other
pseudo-sciences it's not based on
evidence astrological claims are usually
not falsifiable or even testable
astrology hasn't been proven right but
in some respects it can't even be proven
wrong which should always be a red flag
so first of all astrology is not to be
confused with astronomy which is the
actual scientific study of celestial
bodies and everything in space astrology
holds the belief that everything
happening in space has a direct causal
relationship with human events a number
of ancient societies had their own
versions of astrology in Mesoamerica
India China Greece and Rome Babylonia
parts of the Middle East all of these
ancient civilizations and others a long
time ago started to assign significance
to the cycles and positions of celestial
bodies trying to relate them to things
happening on earth and this continued
throughout the Middle Ages for most of
astrology's history astrology and
astronomy were synonymous in other words
astrology was the best astronomy humans
had during this time it's true that
accurate observations of the stars and
planet
what we think of as astronomy was the
foundation of astrology and that's still
true about astrology today to some
degree but astrology and astronomy began
to split apart during the 17th and 18th
centuries as more modern versions of
science began developing and the
supernatural claims made by astrology
were challenged so astrology was
abandoned in the intellectual world and
astronomy has been firmly considered a
separate distinct discipline since the
late 18th century and this is worth
noting that the split between astrology
and astronomy happened upon the
emergence of the scientific method
that's not a coincidence but it sort of
makes sense that pre science humans
would think that the Stars were sending
the messages or influencing human
affairs think about the last time you
could see the Stars clearly it's
awe-inspiring ancient cultures that
didn't have natural explanations for
what they were seeing would
unsurprisingly invent their own
explanations humans are programmed to
make inferences about things they don't
understand so astrology is really just a
way of thinking that is left over from
outdated attempts at science but don't
get me wrong astrology can be very
intricate it can seem scientific enough
because tracking planets and
constellations is something that real
scientists do using complex equations
and charts and a ton of math and this is
why many people are tricked into
thinking astrology is science but I
could use formulas and math to track the
blades of grass in a park to make
predictions about the stock market the
formulas and math don't actually make it
meaningful
astrology believes the time of your
birth and the position of celestial
bodies at that time can determine your
personality strengths weaknesses
compatibility with people born at other
times and more who you should befriend
who you should date decisions you should
make in life and central to astrology
our horoscopes which make predictions
about people's behavior and destinies
based on where and when they were born
which determines what's known as their
Sun Sign
like virgo libra Scorpio Sagittarius we
see horoscopes all over the place
let's look at a random horoscope I found
I didn't cherry pick this this was the
first horoscope I found online quote
everyone looks to you for the answers
today but that doesn't rattle you at all
you're one cool customer and nothing is
going to get the better of you
maybe it's healthy confidence or a bit
of self delusion the reason for your
grace under pressure is irrelevant what
matters is that you'll be there for the
people who need you and your actions
will say everything that needs to be
said you could argue that what I just
read is how most people feel on most
days the whole point is its general
enough for parts to apply to anyone and
to seem relatable to anyone who reads it
on any random day there have been many
experiments where a roomful of people
get the same horoscope people with
different astrological signs and almost
everybody in the room says the horoscope
is accurate and relevant to their lives
people tend to rate claims about them as
accurate if they're vague enough and if
the person thinks that the claim was
tailored to them separating the
population into twelve signs that each
get their own horoscope gives this
illusion of a personally tailored claim
and the writers of horoscopes take
advantage of what's called self-serving
bias where people agree more in general
with flattering or positive descriptions
of themselves or their situation
horoscopes are rarely specific and they
almost never tell you about how horrible
your day is going to be or what a bad
person you are
even though bad days and bad people
obviously exist check out your own
horoscope for today on different
websites and see how different they are
they're being written by people who are
interpreting the sky in different ways
but even if all of the horoscopes were
the same it still wouldn't indicate that
the position of the stars relative to
when you were born had anything to do
with what's happening in your life and
almost all modern Western astrology is
derived from ancient middle-eastern
astrological traditions and involves
some form of horoscope an actual
horoscope is a chart that diagrams the
positions of the Sun Moon and planets
and lets you track the angles that were
created when you draw lines between them
you take that information and
compare it to the exact time and place
of a person's birth or some other event
to make determinations about someone's
innate characteristics or what will
happen in the future but astrology and
horoscopes can get infinitely more
complex and elaborate than newspaper
horoscopes depending on the astrologer
astrologers are usually intimately
familiar with astrology and they charge
people money for readings different
astrologers have their own methods and
many astrologers claim that their
methods are the right ones many people
pay hundreds of bucks an hour to consult
professional astrologers who often are
also doubling as life coaches using star
and planetary charts to give advice
about people's lives
there are many astrologers in the u.s.
that earn six-figure incomes but let's
ask ourselves how could astrology even
work what bearing could the position of
celestial bodies have on human affairs
objects that are millions or even
billions of miles away how could their
positions affect you at your birth much
less right now and if you're thinking
gravity Carl Sagan once pointed out that
the gravitational pull of the people in
the room during your birth would affect
you more than the gravitational pull of
other planets in our solar system why
don't we take into account the position
of the other people who were standing in
the room when you were born was your
mom's OBGYN particularly heavy that
would have more gravitational impact
than the position of a distant star or
planet and astrologers often even break
things down to the hour that you were
born what's so special about the moment
that you were born your biology had
already been developing in your mother's
womb for months none of this survives
even the most basic scrutiny consider
there being two twins born at the same
time in the same place same planets are
in the same places when they're born the
Sun is in the same place think about how
likely it is that they will lead
entirely different lives have entirely
different relationships with other
people have different challenges
different goals one might even die young
while the other lives on astrology
wouldn't have known in 1958 British say
just registered 2,000 babies born in
early March their development was
monitored 110 relevant variables were
measured at ages 11 16 and 23 including
relationship status IQ test scores
teacher and parent ratings of behavior
height weight vision hearing self
ratings of ability with art music and
sports and the study found no evidence
that these people had any
characteristics in common that could be
statistically correlated and why would
they
according to a 2013 Harris Poll 29
percent of Americans say they believe in
astrology and data from the National
Science Foundation suggests that the
number is increasing Ronald Reagan's
chief of staff has said that Nancy
Reagan cleared some decisions with her
personal astrologer astrology can be fun
it can be entertaining if that's how we
use it but it's not based in reality and
it's not a good mechanism for making
important decisions it can give us an
overly fatalistic outlook on life when
we assume that our destinies are
predetermined by the time of year we
were born can also give us false hope or
an inflated sense of self or a false
sense of Doom and we shouldn't ignore
that it's a multi-million dollar
industry astrological readings are a
massive waste of money we are connected
to the rest of the universe and maybe
that's what believers in astrology are
recognizing maybe that's the principle
that they're latching on to human bodies
really are made of Stardust and that's
pretty astonishing and the Sun does have
a profound impact on human life it
allows life on earth to exist with the
light and the warmth that it provides
why not just be captivated by that but
there is no evidence that were connected
to the rest of the universe in the way
that astrology suggests given what we
know about the universe today it's
actually a form of arrogance to think
that humans are the focal point of the
universe it's a primitive superstition
there are plenty of mesmerizing truths
about the universe and celestial bodies
and how they relate to the earth and
human life in ways that are
scientifically justifiable and maybe
those are the facts we should be
thinking about and
be amazed by and fascinated with there
are already enough scientifically sound
findings in physics astronomy and
cosmology to keep us entranced by the
universe and our place in it
we don't need astrology and if you
really want to learn more about the
wonders of the universe the real ones
from a scientific perspective through
the disciplines of astronomy cosmology
and physics the best place to start is
class - central.com / pakman class
central lets you take entire college
courses online from top universities
including Harvard other Ivy League
schools MIT Stanford Berkeley whether
you're interested in science politics
philosophy psychology there are tens of
thousands of courses to choose from on
basically any topic imaginable most of
them are totally free and class central
even has hundreds of free online courses
from leading universities that actually
allow you to receive college credit or
you can audit a class if you just want
to watch lectures from some of the most
well-known professors in the world check
it out click the link in the description
to search for a class on a topic that
fascinates you that's class -
central.com / pakman